[Music]
let's go to shelby in dallas texas hey
shelby what's going on
hey how are you guys doing today
outstanding how are you
doing well very cool so what's up
question is about
um how to teach our kids the value of
money
um a little background on us where my
husband and i are in our mid-30s
we've got three kids under four so we're
starting young
debt-free other than our home wow way to
get paid off in a couple years
and thanks to dave and chris we are
everyday millionaires working on
being multi-millionaires wow very cool
congratulations guys we've done thank
you thank you
thank you all we've done most of this
journey without our kids seeing it
so i kind of have a two-part question um
first of all how do we teach them
a foundation of gratitude and
appreciation
starting with toys and birthday gifts
and vacations now
and then later on we're blessed in a
position to pay for cars in college
and then kind of part two of that is how
open are we with our finances our
salaries our budget meetings
and things like that well you'll take on
the easiest one first that's the second
part of that question i'd be
i'd be open to the point if they don't
need to know you know salary and stuff
like that because kids can't be trusted
with that information they'll go to
school and they just think they're
talking their friend they're like hey my
dad makes this much
so i would i would not uh reveal how
much you all make but as far as
uh having your budget meetings in front
of them they see you guys at the kitchen
table or wherever your spot is
talk to them about line items and what
the budget is made of
so instructing uh through transparency i
think that that's a good place right
there i'd be very open about budget and
how you don't do debt and all that kind
of stuff
i just wouldn't share how much you all
make i actually um
shelby i asked dave that question oh you
did um
off air how do i walk like i always want
my kids involved in these conversations
i want my son to see these numbers
and that's exact same wisdom there right
which i don't tell the kids
our salary but i want him to know here's
how much that light bill in dallas texas
cost it's expensive
oh yeah um i openly gripe when i have to
go into the emergency fund and fix the
car
i want him to hear that that's right i'm
like oh man
so hey shelby one thing that i love and
i may be a slightly sadistic parent i
love it when
we're gonna do our budget meeting and i
tell my son hey
you gotta come sit at the table and
listen and he goes
i kind of love that right and i don't do
it every time what age do you start
at that i don't think are there really
too little
yeah i mean one two and four is too
little
right yeah um yeah but what you want to
do
is think of the words you use think of
they're they're picking up your
your bo they're absorbing you they're
picking up your body language and so
if every month you all sit down to do a
budget
and y'all are yelling and fighting and
you're like rolling your eyes at each
other
your kids will understand that money is
a thing to avoid it causes relational
conflict
if it is not silly and absurd but if you
all say hey we're gonna have our budget
meeting and you and you say those words
out loud and y'all sit down at a table
and you all are prepared and you're
planning and the kids are playing in the
floor below you
they begin to absorb that that this is a
natural rhythm of a family
this is what people do every month they
plan
and i would announce it to your kids
this is budget meeting time and so y'all
are going to play on the floor when mom
and dad talk about
how much money we made how much things
cost how much we're going to save how
much we're going to give
and you just begin to teach them that
language and it doesn't become
a the birds and the bees talk
is much better when it is a part of your
daily interactions with your kids
and not when it's some weird event they
remember the event
right yeah i'm uncomfortable already
thinking about it i've had to do it i've
had to do it three times
uh shelby i'd say this i think the
five-year-old i i think once that
four-year-old becomes a five-year-old
kindergarten age
there's no magic age here this isn't a
rule but i think you could start the
conversation about chores
absolutely and start paying them a buck
a week or two bucks a week or whatever
that's right
uh they're they're going to begin to be
to see a really natural relationship
with money
when i put forth effort in other words
work i get compensated
and that's a wonderful little tool
before they ever understand budgets is
just
hey here's the deal and we i think we
still sell them here at ramsey solutions
but we have them uh
we're selling them three or four years
ago at least but my kids still have
um the uh the p banks the piggy banks
that we sell ramsey solutions with the
little red rubber tops and
and it's spin and and and save
and and and you know here's the deal
like they've learned to tithe
and and they kind of get this whole
conversation just really natural as john
said so i think
from that standpoint uh showing them the
value of work
uh and making them earn stuff uh i think
is huge i mean
to this day josie is 12. and uh
i don't know if your daughter's into
this little josephine but these uh
these uh fidget things there's all kinds
of these little
poppets and they're fotzing around these
things and they're really popular with
sixth grade girls apparently
and so she wanted to buy several and i
was like babe
i'm not gonna keep you've got five you
want 15.
go buy them so you know what she showed
up
the other night she said hey mom what
can i do what can i do what can i do
and josie's motivated and i told her i
said i'm proud of you she created a
checklist for a week
and she cut a deal with us we'll pay you
this much i'm happy to do that that's
fantastic
so shelby um i'm getting into ken's
territory here but here's
a cool thing that happens when you start
teaching kids about
work and monetary rewards
is it's a great time to talk about their
role
in the family yeah their purpose what
they contribute
they begin to learn deep in their soul
this family runs does not run without me
i'm a part of this thing
and so what we did with our kids is we
broke up here's a few jobs that we do in
our house that you don't get paid for
it's part of that's right all of us are
together on this
and then i mean you got to go get on the
riding mower and mow momo i'm going to
pay you for that because that stinks
paying you to clean up your room no
that's a part of being a human being
inside the delony house
right and so um one other thing you
talked about gratitude
my wife is is the one that really drove
this home teaching our kids
when they get gifts they don't play with
them until
is a thank you card written and
that's good they go through an entire
dramatic process and the the writing is
awful sometimes it looks like it was
written with somebody's feet right it's
not
great it's it's about the exercise
um and we thought that counts and right
correlation and make
right and another thing that we do she
then again this is my wife's
they created um bags of food that stay
in the car
that we can pass out when folks uh are
on the side of the road
and they need money or help and here's
what we're trying to do we're trying to
teach our kids
that the life they're growing up in is
not everybody's life
in fact it's very few people's life and
you've got to walk through life with
your eyes wide open
for people you can serve and you can
help and be a part of it's about
gratitude
so your wife and my wife dude we've
really out married ourselves there's no
question about it
uh two things that i'll share with you
that stacy did shelby
and we learned this from uh a marriage
mentor a couple that
uh excuse me mentored us early on and
they did this
with their kids we stopped doing this by
the way when the kids got to sixth grade
because of the type of parties
but for each of our three kids birthday
parties starting at the age of three
we would invite their friends over and
their their presence
the the kids present was a really
awesome party
and we told all the parents
don't send gifts with your kid they're
like what
these adults send gifts you come
and you bring food you bring
clothing you bring a toy and so all
three coleman kids
their birthday party was an awesome
bounce house or some cool experience
that was the gift they didn't get toys
from us
they didn't get toys from their friends
because in today's world you do
you do a birthday party for your
five-year-old it's like christmas like
this
toys r us 15 kids show up and every
parent's trying to outdo the other
parent
and so we learned this so what we said
was and people it took them a while
a couple people tried to sneak a gift
and please take it back
and so then and so each of our three
kids shelby would then take
everything that was brought and they
would take it to a children's hospital
if it was toys
they'd take it to a food shelter if it
was food uh that was really
really a beautiful thing and our kids
learned that the party the relationships
the friends
that was your guest that's the magic
right not a toy so at the end of the day
if you distill all the things that ken
and i just said
down into one word it's intentionality
you can't
screw up intentionality with your kids
right
be present with them think through it
let them see your budget let them
see the the fun and the smiles and the
frustrations with budgets make them be
grateful
teach them gratitude i just can't make
them be grateful teach them gratitude